conference will begin momentarily good
morning everybody this is MIT your Alvin
has entered the conference uh welcome
and thank you let me begin by man has
entered the conference uh you're at your
loyalty and friendship Charles Koch has
entered this David Koch has entered the
conference god bless you all one poll
out just today shows me gaining support
and leading the next closest contender
by nearly two to one Rand Paul has left
the conference I also believe I would
have the best chance of beating the
eventual Democrat nominee Hillary
Clinton has left the conference after
putting considerable thought into making
another run for president I've decided
it's best to give other leaders in the
party the opportunity to become our next
nominee Marco Rubio handsome chris
Christie Mike Huckabee has left the
conference accordingly I'm not
organizing a pack or taking donations
Sheldon Adelson has left the conference
at all my supporters friends and family
mark alpha has left the conference
bye-bye